thank you
Sovereign
against the validity of Islam go ahead
against
Islam guess why Islam is a True Religion
why it's valid why so what's your
strongest argument why are you addicted
to social media watching The Champ over
and over again
trying to be like the champ if you want
to be like the champ you have to join
the champ in establishing the
Scandinavian Mega Masjid in Tower Center
in Norway click the link below and
donate now
I've asked him a simple question he's
here to tell me why Islam is wrong I
don't know why tell me what give me your
argument I'm waiting for you
okay so you need to have to help you
whether and the other man's helpful
whether the child will help us it's a
valid whether it's a valid religion is
that what you asked why is Islam wrong
you've come here to tell me you talk
about Islam every week don't you yeah
okay now I'm giving you an opportunity
I'm right here in front of you okay
we've already established your ignoramus
we don't know anything about Islam but
I'm just going to give you the benefit
of the doubt as an unqualified
uncredible deliberately ignorant person
as you are I'm asking the question what
is your strongest argument why is Islam
what's wrong Muhammad it's the strongest
argument that's not that's not an
argument it's a man go ahead yeah it's
an argument because
there are 91 verses in the Quran that
commands the Muslims to imitate the
behavior of Muhammad okay that's why
uh if if you're copying his behavior
you're a good Muslim and Muhammad also
said that himself okay so I don't see
how that's a strong argument against why
Islam is wrong I've just asked you a
question you said you have to imitate
Muhammad
so what if Islam
um
religion a spiritual relationship
between a person and a god it would it
wouldn't be a problem because
what's your strongest argument yes why
is that is wrong is that Islam is not a
religion it's a political Doctrine it's
uh
let's say that let's say Islam has
political doctrines and Military
doctrines why is that wrong go ahead
it's wrong because Islam yeah why cannot
coexist with other systems of governing
societies because
it's not Islam does not accept powerful
arguments yeah it's purple powerful yeah
and you can well held by you can tell by
um by observing the states that has been
invaded and occupied by Islam more than
50 states powerful art you can see all
these states are shitos okay because of
Islam countries that used to be a nice
place to live has become shitos because
of Islam okay and the Muslims behaving
Islamic so that's why we don't want to
so we don't want that to happen so our
country and that is why we'll Deport
summarize your only one what's your
argument your argument is that Islam is
wrong because it has military and
political doctrines yeah so okay so
sorry so in that case liberalism is
wrong because it's a political Doctrine
it is not a religion no but it's a
political Doctrine that's what you just
said yeah but Islam claims to be here
right whether it claims to be religion
liberal liberalism
I can't understand
don't interrupt she said um
it's something I I observe it yes quite
quite often with your Muslims oh yes so
you do observe it with us I thought you
said we didn't follow our religion here
okay kind of behaves like a caveman he's
not able to communicate in a civilized
way okay now and that goes for you too
as an ad hominem it's an ad hominem
Palace do you know that is well no okay
it's another woman you're attacking the
man not the argument I said to you right
now I'm I'm trying to find out that you
are not very good at debating oh really
okay because you don't accept well okay
when you how is this how is this
relevant to what we're talking about
I'll ask you a question right why is
Islam wrong you said because it's a
political and Military doctor okay
you try to to Dragon yes
liberalism is a political philosophy
which has military implications correct
liberals yes liberals and Islam
Islam
Islam Islam the most
it doesn't accept any other political
um socialism uh whatever
you know what happened in Iran in
Lebanon
I want you to rate your point you're
jumping from points to example I want
you to finish your point what is your
point that Islam is incapable of having
people within it um it's a political
tool to implement Sharia okay in a whole
planet okay that's what uh
okay so and we have to let's go
make it wrong why does that make it
wrong why that is wrong yeah we don't
want Islam to destroy our country
because we have a quite nice place here
okay so what happens you know I find you
know why I finally you speak yeah now
can you let me respond could you talk
about caveman I don't want you to be a
caveman yeah okay so you're you're the
Civilized white man and I'm the caveman
but let me just let me indulge me for a
second here indulge me indulge me let me
say this
isn't it interesting that this man is
talking about Islam as being incapable
of Tolerance yet his very prescription
is incapable of Tolerance itself in
other words his prescription of
deporting Muslims is exactly intolerance
so he's he doesn't like Islam because of
his alleged claim that it's intolerant
yet his own prescriptions are intolerant
in nature
so what you just witnessed there really
was a kind of jihad what did you say a
kind of jihad are you an extremist I
knew you were a violent extremist no no
no
no no no you don't understand what the
word Jihad means you see the prophet
Muhammad sallam told us
that struggle in the way of Allah with
your money meaning give charity
yes there is a physical Jihad and the
third one
and with your tongues and the Quran says
we struggle with the Quran we make
intellectual arguments based on the
quranic argumentation
now you can join this kind of jihad this
intellectual Jihad yes you can join it
and what is the incentive Allah says in
the Quran
[Music]
um
foreign
[Music]
oh you who believe
should I let you know of a trait of a
bargain of a business
that will
keep you away from
a painful punishment
Allah's telling me is telling you he's
asking me he's asking you this question
then he tells us
that you believe in Allah and his
messenger
with
Jihad that you struggle in the way of
Allah
with your monies with your monies and
with yourselves
that is better for you if you only knew
what will Allah give us he tells us in
the next verse
he will erase your sins
he will forgive your sins
that then he will put us into Gardens
wherein which
rivers flow
can you imagine
and beautiful houses places of
inhabitation
in The Gardens of Eden
and this is the great reward is this
something you you can forgo is this
something you're willing to forgo do we
really believe in these things do we
really believe in heaven do we really
believe in hell do we really believe in
the punishment of Allah
if so
then we cannot afford to let an
opportunity like this go
you're one click away potentially one
click away on this holy month
of fulfilling all of the conditions of
this area
one click away
it won't even take you as long as it
will take to put a bread in a toaster
and then it pop out
how long how long why procrastinate why
be lazy why be stingy
um
Allah says whoever eliminates the
stinginess from themselves then they are
the ones who are successful
press the button below now do not miss
this opportunity